what would you say to the people and I
hear well-known authors say this often
that we at some point within the next
hundred years we're gonna have to leave
this little planet this little rock that
we're on that has some green and happens
to have the right cosmic mix of stuff
for life or that we're gonna actually
have to go and that's sort of the point
of humanity that will use it up here and
then we'll move on you can see I watch
out of sci-fi do you also what what
would you say about that there's no
place that we can get to and there's a
lot of risk in space of radiation and
other things as they'll see when they
send a man to Mars which you're probably
gonna do soon yeah you'll see the
effects of just getting fifty seven
million miles which is nothing compared
and Mars the idea of setting up a
station there what would you do on Mars
how would you grow food there the kind
of biosphere remember that thing buyers
remember these words you know the idea
they were not even remotely
self-sufficient they had a big natural
gas generator there to generate a fair
amount of the power yeah and even then
people got sick and there was all kinds
of problems I think they found out that
someone was coming and going from this
ya know and there was like some sort of
mold or fungus that got in there in that
closed ecosystem yeah it's very hard the
idea of having a spare planet somewhere
is folly I don't think we I don't think
that's gonna you think this is yeah this
is as good as it gets for life as we
know it we need to make this as
hospitable it has always been a
hospitable planet for us in our history
before we were born millions of years
ago is volcanic and very inhospitable
but it's been a it's been in a sweet
spot for a while and we have to keep it
there with our behavior as best we can
on that note you have any last minute
tips I think you've given us some good
stuff here but for the average person
that doesn't even care about this stuff
what are like the two most simple things
that you could tell someone all right go
ahead and try to incorporate some of
this at the root of it just live simply
so others can simply live try to keep
your life as simple as possible having
said that a tip a new tip that I like to
tell people is about something called
vampire power unplug all that stuff that
you don't need when you go to sleep or
leave the house there's a lot of things
that you think you need on all the time
then you don't in fact it's a short list
of things that you need on like your
clock radio your you know whatever
things like that
that are gonna be blinking midnight when
you come back you plug those in into a
power strip and leave them alone on the
other power strips you put all those
little Transformers little plugs and
things put them in there and one two
three perhaps is all it'll be around
your house turn off those power strips
at night when you leave the house you'll
save a tremendous amount of money
all right well ed begley it has been a
pleasure I'm glad we finally got to do
this in person this is better than 140
characters right you're pretty good
question I like it a lot better
very good David that's a lot better I
appreciate that and you guys can check
out and show on Begley Street it is on
YouTube we're gonna annotate to it right
around here it's here somewhere
and of course on Twitter anything else
we should pimp out no that's plenty
about her Earth in general Earth in
general protect your protect alright
there you go